et que toutes les cops depuis la COP 21
et si je n'étais pas au départ de la
Route du Rhum je serai probablement
acharné le chèque je suis co-fondatrice
de la plateforme océan et climat et je
sais que les perturbations les
conditions météo un peu brutales qu'on
aurait pu avoir dimanche on les doit au
réchauffement de l'océan en profondeur
ça nous a été dit 2 degrés de plus
l'océan qui ce matin au briefing météo
qui fait qu'on a des dépressions
tropicales qui reprennent la circulation
d'ouest et qui sont assez violentes donc
on est au cœur du sujet là on est
vraiment au coeur du sujet donc voilà si
ça peut aider les Terriens à comprendre
qu'il est urgent d'agir c'est voilà on
est là aussi pour ça je pense en tous
les cas moi je suis là pour ça aussi